federal judge is preventing the bide
administration from rolling back title
42.
that is the emergency measure put into
place by the trump administration that
allowed the u.s government to deport
migrants without allowing them to apply
for asylum due to the risk they might
spread covert 19.
christina rafini is at the white house
where the administration is planning to
appeal the judge's ruling christina good
morning to you
good morning jeff this ruling was more
of a technical one than based on the
merits of the program this federal judge
who's a trump appointee
said the bite administration couldn't
end title 42 without this mandatory
public comment period something that
didn't happen now the administration had
hoped to stop this program on monday
it's likely to last for a couple months
at this point and even though democrats
have been pressuring the biden
administration to end title 42 and allow
migrants to apply for asylum in
accordance with international law the
biden administration has actually used
the program longer and to expel more
individuals than the trump
administration 1.4 million according to
an analysis of cpb data now some of our
colleagues interviewed the dhs secretary
along the border this week and he argues
that the title 42 program actually works
against efforts to stop illegal
immigration because there's no mechanism
by which to prosecute repeat offenders
right people just get expelled and then
come right back over the border dana
all right christina thank you